okay I'm gonna get right into it just
because there's so much to talk about we
are talking about the bar reports some
people are calling it the Moller report
it's really not it's really the bar
report Donald Trump's Attorney General
issuing a four-page summary which is his
interpretation of parts of the Moller
report which we will hopefully someday
be able to see and there I already did
so we recorded today's broadcast show
earlier that's already been airing on
radio and TV stations and which will
continue to go out on YouTube during the
day but already in the few hours since
we filmed today's show there has been so
much truly disturbing an ignorant stuff
circulating regarding this report and
regarding what is in it what is not in
it what it means what it doesn't mean
and the reactions from the right have
been predictable which is to say that on
the say-so of Trump's attorney general
Trump did nothing wrong which for most
people doesn't pass the sniff test but
there are also some sort of strange
things coming from the left and we're
going to talk about that I'll tell you
in addition to sort of explaining what
is and isn't in the bar report we'll
talk about the gloating that's confusing
or doesn't make sense we'll also talk
about the idea of whether given what has
transpired the molar probe was quote
worth it that's another sort of element
of this that people are emailing me
about which I do plan to address we will
then also talk about what was not what
we learned we didn't know the full scope
of what Robert Muller was and wasn't
looking into while the investigation was
going on if we are to believe a G bars
four page summary there are really
important elements of this entire thing
that Robert Muller reportedly didn't
even look into so we're going to deal
with that as well and I may open up the
phone lines and take your phone calls
maybe not I can tell from the comments
that I'm already seeing that a lot of
people want to crush me for what I said
that was so wrong about the molar probe
and I look forward to some of those
calls because if they're anything like
the emails I've been getting
think they're going to be pretty pretty
entertaining so welcome to the live
stream if you are if it is 6:30 to p.m.
Eastern Time on March 25th 2019 this is
live unlike the video clips that we
upload to YouTube from our national TV
and radio show this means that you can
participate in the discussion
use super chat to ask questions and send
comments that is the dollar symbol at
the bottom of the chat window comments
and questions can be about anything
certainly we're going to be digging into
the bar report quite a bit but I will
take super chats about anything you want
sign up for membership at WWE pakman.com
if we get 10 new members or channel
subscribers during the stream I will
open up the phone lines and I can
already see a bunch of people calling in
I haven't even mentioned the phone line
but I can already see people coming in
it's just going to voicemail right now
if you want the phone lines open and it
seems people do probably to talk about
the Moller probe well we've got to get
10 new members and you can get us on the
way to that by signing up at
www.sceeto.com below which will allow
you to join as a youtube channel member
we will count any of those towards
the 10 new memberships to open the phone
lines but to be clear we keep only 70%
of the YouTube channel memberships we
keep 97% of memberships on our website
which is why it's such a great thing
total control over the process okay so
we're where to even start I guess I just
just first get some basics out there
right so Robert Muller submitted his
report to the Attorney General on Friday
the Attorney General
William bar condensed and summarized it
in a way he saw fit and published
yesterday a four page summary now the
reaction from trumpets was absolute and
total vindication the reaction from
those in Trump's circle and from himself
absolutely clears the president no
collusion blah blah blah and the
reaction from some on the Left
interestingly was also this proves Trump
didn't collude all of you Russia Gators
were wrong now I can really only speak
for myself I don't watch anything so if
you're going to say well David what
about what ex person or Y person said
that Trump was going to be caught
red-handed colluding with Putin I can't
speak for what they said but I've been
saying for more than a year at this
point if you're hoping that Trump is
going to be personally caught red-handed
colluding quote with Putin or with
Russia it's simply not going to happen
what we have here is a much more nuanced
situation it's extraordinarily unlikely
that anything that Trump personally did
in terms of collusion would rise to the
level of definitive criminality such
that we would see an indictment it's
about the cover-up as far as Trump's
concerned obstruction is one example
that was not ruled out by Moeller and
it's about other people many of whom
have been indicted remember 37
indictments here so when I see people
say this clears Trump of collusion in
all ways shapes and forms know what this
tells us is that in the particular
narrow scope that Robert Moeller looked
into quote collusion he did not find
sufficient evidence to recommend charges
and of course any sensible person would
realize this is not about Trump meeting
with Putin and saying help me help me
win Vlad help me win that's never what
it was about now very very importantly
when we talk about the obstruction piece
even William bars politicized summary of
this entire thing says Robert Moeller is
not able to exonerate Donald Trump when
it comes to obstruction of justice and
has effectively punted to William Bar to
decide about
whether Donald Trump should or should
not be charged with obstruction this is
extraordinarily important for two to
five reasons or something like that the
most important reason that it's relevant
that robert muller is punting to AG bar
to decide whether donald trump
obstructed the investigation is that AG
bar a year ago already said he doesn't
believe topline forget about the facts
that a president can be indicted for
obstruction so when you wonder the molar
probe went on for however long it went
on and an extraordinarily extensive and
detailed report was presumably given to
William Bar on Friday and by Sunday he
knew that obstruction of justice charges
weren't appropriate against Donald Trump
how could that be it's because the
evidence doesn't matter
AG bar was selected specifically because
it was known that his view on a
president being charged with obstruction
of justice is that they cannot be so if
you put someone in there who just said
at a systemic level doesn't believe you
can be charged you're gonna do pretty
well importantly and I want to add
historically it's the house that
determines obstruction charges if you go
back to Nixon and we're gonna do this on
tomorrow's program why would the
Attorney General that was selected by
the president decide whether the person
that selected them should be charged
with obstruction of justice it doesn't
pass the sniff test because it shouldn't
because it makes no sense and
historically we're gonna go back to 1974
I believe it is it's the house of
representatives that should be making
that evaluation and of course unless
they get the full report about the full
Robert Moeller report they're not really
going to be in a position to do that so
those are sort of the first two bullet
points that I wanted to address on
today's stream let me look briefly at a
couple of Super chats and then we'll
continue just because I anticipate
there's going to be a lot of interest in
what we've got going on a horror fan for
life says this is true horror film Trump
is off the hook I think that that's the
wrong approach
Trump was never going to go down
for making a plan with Putin to steal
the election if you were waiting for
that it was a it was a pipe dream I
don't know of any serious analysts who
were saying that that's what they were
expecting but if you were waiting for
that it was an unrealistic expectation
horror fan for life also adding in all
seriousness I'm just bummed out and sad
listen the sadness of this is just that
everything happened in exactly the way
we would predict the investigation went
on long enough with enough public
scrutiny from Trump and his cronies that
Donald Trump was able to put in place
the people he needed to put in place
like for example his own attorney
general to decide whether he obstructed
obstructed justice he was able in
addition to that to avoid answering
actual questions to Robert Muller we
learned and I'll get to this that Robert
Moeller didn't look at Russian business
connections prior to the election nor
meetings and actions that took place
after the election so of course he was
never going to find that Donald Trump
personally colluded to the extent that
that's a crime and we know that
collusion in and of itself is not so I
think you know it's important to reframe
if Robert Moeller had been doing this
investigation all along we didn't hear
about indictments we didn't hear about
convictions we didn't hear about guilty
pleas and on Friday
Robert Muller had announced I'm
submitting my report to william bar
here's a list of 37 indictments here's a
list of the people that have already
pled guilty here's a list of the people
who have been convicted here's a list of
how what prison sentences they are doing
that would be much more newsworthy in
the feeling that this was a big
accomplishment but we've had indictments
and convictions and guilty pleas and
prison sentences all along
so now Muller says we're not going
further Trump didn't collude personally
horsey didn't so it's really an issue of
perspective and I want to say most
importantly I don't I don't know what's
going on in the chat but I assume people
are saying David when will you admit you
were wrong tell me exactly what it is I
need to admit because I've been saying
for more than a year we're relying on
the Moller investigation to remove Trump
to lead to impeachment to lead to
removal under the 25th amendment
to lead to indictment it's not gonna
happen it's not a political strategy
Democrats can't win if that's what
they're running on it's extraordinarily
unlikely that will happen the collusion
or coordination with Russia is not
Donald Trump personally doing this stuff
Trump has been sort of lulled into these
weird relationships with Russians for a
very long time money laundering
absolutely other crimes absolutely
but Trump on collusion was never
something that we were waiting around
for so find instances of me saying
something else and then we'll talk okay
let me pause on the super chats but by
all means keep sending them in we will
also if people want me to open up the
phone lines I'm willing to do it if and
when we get 10 new subscribers on our
website six one seven eight three zero
47 50 is my direct line we will open up
that direct line if and when we get 10
new members and we got one Geoffrey
Dickens Geoffrey Dickens has signed up
you go to WWE Ackman comm and you can
use the coupon code this is 2020 to save
40% we are at one new member if we get
to ten I'll open up the phone lines from
you for you and no call screening if you
want to slam me if you want to trash me
if you want to tell me how wrong I am
about everything I will have no way of
preventing you from doing that since we
don't screen calls okay so the next
thing I want to address is specifically
a contingent of the left that is sort of
accepting a G bars four-page letter as
gospel and truth in a way that they
never do with anyone else associated
with the Trump administration what I
mean is the following when Sarah
Huckabee Sanders gets up there and gives
us her interpretation of a document that
was published by whoever we don't just
say hey Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
summarizing it like this so I'm sure
she's telling us the truth
when Trump's Secretary of State comes
out
and says Isis has been defeated and Kim
jong-un is no longer a threat whatever
right
we don't say listen Mike Pompeo said it
I'm sure he's giving us the truth we
don't have to be skeptical about that at
all so it's very weird to me when
Attorney General Barr summarizes a
report no one has seen in a way that is
as favorable to Donald Trump as
conceivably possible with the exception
of including in there that Muller
doesn't exonerate Trump on the issue of
obstruction and some of those same
people who rightly apply that skepticism
when it's Sarah Huckabee Sanders or
Betsy DeVos or Mike Pompeo or whoever
say this is the truth William Barr said
it so therefore it's the truth this was
a calculated decision dating all the way
back to the shenanigans of temporarily
installing Matthew Whitaker after
pushing Jeff Sessions out who was
recused on Russia and then letting
Attorney General Barr take over that
this was the plan there's a great
article in Esquire about it and it would
be great if I saw more people that are
supposedly on the Left kind of applying
that same degree of criticism on the
question of the personally colluded with
Putin I don't know who was waiting
around for that revelation but on a lot
of this other stuff if and when we get
the full molar report there is no doubt
that there is going to be a ton of
damaging stuff and they're not the least
reason is that Trump is already
activating to try to prevent his written
testimony to Robert Muller from being
released and that there has been no move
thus far to actually get the Moller
report released so that that I'm finding
very very strange
now the other very important element of
this is again right now all we have is
what William bar told us and I can't
imagine that that is the full extent of
the situation but it appears that Robert
Muller completely skipped or didn't
include in this investigation large
swaths of the potential potentially
relevant occurrences from this entire
thing what I mean by that is all along
Trump and his cronies were insisting
Robert molar is casting too wide a net
it's just he's going too far he's
supposed to be narrowly focused here on
collusion and what we found out at least
from Rob William bars four-page letter
is that basically Mulder was focused on
collusion and he looked at obstruction
but is not making a judgment call one
way or the other which is
extraordinarily disturbing as I already
discussed the issue of financial
connections before the election doesn't
appear to have been looked at by Robert
Moeller the issue of meetings and
contacts attempts to create back
channels all of this stuff that was
swirling in the media and we were
sitting back saying I'm sure molars
looking at it right I'm sure this is
part of what Robert Muller is looking
into from what we saw in william bars
four-page letter it actually doesn't
appear that that's the case which is
extraordinarily concerning and again
hopefully something that it looks like
William bar is going to be subpoenaed to
testify before the house maybe as soon
as this week there are rumblings of
bringing Robert Miller to testify will
we ever learn about this stuff who knows
and again I can't help but go back to
what I've been saying for more than a
year if you thought that this
investigation was the path to the
removal of Donald Trump you were
extraordinarily confused or misguided or
simply didn't have all of the
information and that's why for more than
a year now I've been saying the quickest
way to remove Trump is going to be to
vote him out in November of 2020 that's
going to require Democrats having a
strategy that is not impeach Trump or
extend the Moller probe as long as
possible or any of those things and that
I wasn't the only person saying it it
was a relatively obvious observation and
it does appear to be coming to fruition
at this point in time although we will
of course continue following what else
comes as a result of this let me do a
couple of other super chats that are
coming in here I will remind you that we
will potentially open up the phone lines
if we get 10 new members on our website
david pakman.com slash membership
there's a coupon code that will save you
35 bucks off of the
$60.00 membership a le membership is
$60.00 for the year and a very
reasonable price at that I might mention
but if you want to drop that $60 price
to just 25 bucks and it's not a low low
low introductory price it is a price you
can keep for as long as you want use the
coupon code save 35 okay that's two
bucks a month I think a lot of people in
the audience do believe the program is
worth two bucks a month for them and if
you do and that's affordable please do
sign up and that'll get us to open up
the phone lines as well it something
must be going on because I look the
phone system right now is on go direct
to voicemail and like every 20 seconds a
voicemail is popping up meaning a lot of
people are trying to call in but of
course the phone lines are not yet open
our only new member of the evening so
far is Geoffrey Dickens glad to open the
phone lines if we get nine more new
members let's see what else is on
people's minds via super chat the
Asperger peddler says why do you think
many on the left view Andrew yang as a
libertarian in progressive clothing I
don't know I mean he has a mix of
policies he Andrew Yang's policies are a
mix of social democracy and a sort of
civil social libertarianism with a sort
of entrepreneurial consultant
perspective I guess I would say so I
don't think as a general assessment that
is that's accurate
BYO be b12 with a $5 superjet David do
you think if Trump's usefulness to
Russia ever ends they will give out the
dirt they have on him - so more
political chaos sure yeah sure I mean we
don't we don't know what they have we
don't know the full extent of any of
this stuff what we do know is look at
what Russian geo politicians have said
like Alexandre Dugan in his 1997 book
foundations of geopolitics the the idea
is it's not about supporting left or
right wing candidates in the US
it's not about supporting candidates
that push a particular ideology although
certainly some candidates are more
useful to Russia than others it's about
creating chaos making Americans question
whether their systems of democracy are
working sewing racial discord and all of
these other things and to kind of follow
your suggestion if indeed Russia does
have stuff on Trump it's not
they are amoral in the sense that
there's no particular loyalty to Trump
as an individual if Trump's usefulness
as a chaotic as a chaos causer
in American politics ends and they do
have stuff on Trump sure why wouldn't
they release it
mr. Segura with a dollar ninety nine
super chat says I need an option to sign
up without my name read on the air well
you can put any name in for membership I
mean our website accepts any name you
could put in that your name is Donald
Trump and that's the name that would pop
up
doesn't matter what name is on your
credit or debit card doesn't matter what
name is on the PayPal account that you
use so put in when you sign up on our
website any name you want as long as
your email address is correct and your
payment goes through I will say that
your name is Humpty Dumpty if that's
what you type in so no no issues there
whatsoever
Jason Zaremba says have you heard of the
podcast chapo trap trap chapo trap trap
house or is it chapo trap house they
would be great to have on the show very
popular I've heard of it I've never
heard a single episode but I am I am
familiar with the podcast couldn't name
a single person on it with Sebastian
with an 8 euro super chat coming from
the Netherlands the United States has
become a joke to many of us I still put
my trust in you am I wrong to do so do
you mean me personally
Sebastian or whoever is with Sebastian
listen I do the best job I can I'm not
doing news reporting I'm doing analysis
and commentary my recommendation I would
be a hypocrite if I told you we have to
approach assertions with healthy
skepticism we need to trust but verify
we need to find multiple sources on any
issue but then I said except with me you
can just believe every
thing I say no fact-check me call and
question me when we take phone calls
find other sources of course it would be
complete and utter hypocrisy for me to
suggest anything else what I think is
not in question is that I don't take
political positions on this sort of
calculated basis in order to check a box
or be put under a certain umbrella or
place on the political spectrum I mean
on all issues for as long as I've done
the show I just tell you what I think
and sometimes that causes disagreements
even with people that we would consider
sort of like in the core of my audience
but the reason I'm able to do that is
number one I don't have anyone tell me
telling me what the editorial line needs
to be because I'm in charge here and
there's no sort of like higher up that
says you can cover this story or you
can't cover that one and number two
funding is not connected to how I do or
don't cover any issue now it's possible
imagine for example that I said you know
what I've become conservative my view on
abortion it's just changed my view on
supply-side economics it has changed and
now I think that we need god-fearing
Christian politicians and whatever okay
so I'm guessing that that would disgust
enough people in the audience that then
they would start canceling memberships
and our financial support would would
start to erode but we've been lucky
enough for the most part that the people
that support the show are not supporting
the show because they necessarily agree
with me on every issue I can't imagine
anyone agrees with me a hundred percent
of the time but my my sense is from the
emails that I get people recognize that
when the david pakman show is funded by
viewers that means I say whatever I want
and as long as I'm not fundamentally
becoming a conservative having a
ridiculous political awakening that puts
me on some other place in the political
spectrum part of the value is that no
one's telling me what to say and I'm
always just going to tell you what I
think and that is I think the most
important thing so to your question
should you trust me
you can trust that I will always tell it
to you as I see it and to the best of my
knowledge as I've researched it can I
sometimes get things wrong sure
can you come away with different
conclusions than I come away absolutely
and that's that's all great as long as
everybody is sort of acting in a in a
genuine way let me welcome and say thank
you to John Campbell John Campbell now I
wonder if this is the John Campbell no
it's not okay based on John Campbell's
email I know a John Campbell who spells
his name exactly that way and I was
wondering if maybe that's uh that's who
it was so that's two out of ten to new
members the target for the evening is
ten new members if and when we get to
ten new members I'll open up the phone
lines and I see in the chat that a lot
of people people who aren't talking
about Ivanka Trump's private parts or
saying anti-semitic things to me seem to
want to talk to me about all the things
that I'm wrong about which is fine I
will open the phone lines six one seven
eight three zero 47 50 if you so please
we're just looking for ten new signups
we have two new signups so far okay a
couple of articles I'm looking at for
tomorrow's program there's a very
interesting article from NBC News fake
news failing and BC news I'm kidding
whether Trump obstructed justice isn't
the Attorney General's called to make
its Congress's decision I am going to be
talking about this tomorrow there's a
particular article of paragraph in the
article here which is this one which I
find extraordinarily relevant let me see
if I can frame it properly the
impeachment inquiry of President Richard
Nixon adhered to the approach of
investigating the facts and then
allowing Congress to draw its own
conclusions a four ten to four vote by
the House of Representatives in February
of 74 authorizing the house judiciary
committee to investigate fully and
completely whether sufficient grounds
existed to him
each President Nixon after which an
impeachment inquiry staff of the
committee on which I served set to work
under the leadership of John doar
distinguished former Assistant Attorney
General the inquiry staff provided 650
statements of information 7,200 pages
etc etc in its final report following
the adoption of three articles of
impeachment against President Nixon the
Judiciary Committee emphasized that
these 36 volumes of statements of
information were strictly factual a
deliberate and scrupulous abstention
from conclusions even by implication was
observed the molar reports apparent
similarity to the 74 statements of
information is striking he developed and
organized the facts as the impeachment
inquiry staff did leaving it to
decision-makers to reach their
conclusions but that bar has are
unsurprisingly reached one conclusion
does not foreclose Congress from
reaching the opposite conclusion it
should indeed be Congress that analyzes
the information surrounding whether or
not Donald Trump obstructed justice you
and I may both agree it was never likely
that Trump was going to be caught
red-handed colluding with Russia but he
appeared to be obstructing the
investigation in plain sight in by the
light of day and it simply cannot be up
to his attorney general to decide
whether Donald Trump did or did not
obstruct justice and that is an
extraordinarily important element which
I am going to be talking about tomorrow
secondly this is an article from the LA
Times arguing that not only was the
Moller investigation not a waste it was
also not a hoax and I apologize for the
zoom I'm sort of like unable to get this
it's gonna be too zoomed out I think now
for us to read it maybe not the
important thing that I want to point out
here and we may also drill into this on
tomorrow's show once again is that if on
the day that the investigation ended we
had learned about the 37 indictments and
the convictions
and the guilty pleas and the jail time
it would be much less easy for anyone to
say the whole thing was a waste of time
if the molar probe hadn't recovered more
funds than it cost by virtue of
settlements fraud money that was
recovered etc etc it would be much
easier to say it was a waste and or a
hoax it's important not to lose
perspective that we learned about
indictments over a very long period of
time and at a certain point Muller was
done and turned over other cases to
other law enforcement divisions
including the SDN why I get it I get why
it feels like man nothing really
happened add up everything that happened
all the people that went to jail all the
people that were convicted etc that are
going to jail and you quickly realize
not only was it not a waste it also was
not a hoax okay let me thank another
couple of people here
mr. Segura has signed up for a David
Pakman show membership at WWJ pakman.com
mr. Segura has used the coupon code this
is 20 20 beautiful thing about that when
you apply the coupon code this is 20 20
to the $6 a month membership it drops by
40%
to only three dollars and 60 cents per
month I also want to say thanks to two
other YouTube members with Sebastian is
a new YouTube channel member using the
join button down below that's number
four and mg is a new YouTube member also
using the join button down below so that
gets us the 5 out of 10 if we get to 10
new members this evening I will open up
the phone lines now I know that very
often by the time we get the phone lines
open I only can take calls for like 10
or 15 minutes I actually do have more
time to take calls this evening I don't
have to get to my next thing for a
little bit so if people want me to
really get a chance to dig into the
phone lines more than I often am able to
tonight is a good night to get those 10
new members and we will
hopefully be hearing from a bunch of
people soon super chat from Jared
Johnson 20 Mexican pesos have food
stamps helped eliminate malnutrition uh
well they've helped but they've not
eliminated it I don't know I have a
feeling there's some kind of political
implication with the question the issue
about malnutrition and hunger is is a
truly sad and disgusting one because
it's not even a matter of money it's a
matter of political will because by most
estimates we're only getting oh people
are only eating somewhere between 35 and
50 percent of food that is produced okay
this includes stuff that spoils in
transit this includes stuff that is just
bruised but okay and ends up getting
thrown out either by the grower or the
wholesaler or the grocery store this
includes food waste at in our kitchens
right it's sort of the end of the
process so solving hunger completely and
by virtue of that to a great degree
malnutrition it's not a financial issue
it's it's really just an issue of
political will and organizing some
logistics and as a result of that
problems that we can so easily solve I
find particularly immoral and pernicious
that that we haven't solved and in fact
I've done some research into this and
we've done a couple of interviews on the
subject we as a planet don't even need
to have hunger in other words as a
planet we are creating enough food
everyday that every person on the planet
can get the calories they need maybe in
some cases it would be a slightly
calorically restricted diet by ten or
fifteen percent but you would eliminate
this sort of abject hunger that exists
and we're not doing it and it's just not
I mean listen our political system
doesn't lend itself to it if you work
for your six years that you have in the
Senate on reducing hunger in the United
States and some other country or
whatever and breaking news you
reduced hunger by 10% in a country 90%
of that hunger is still there it doesn't
make for a good story on the news it's
not the type of thing that our political
system fundamentally encourages and as a
result of that it's just not become a
political priority it's disgusting it's
sad it's it's incredibly depressing but
we need to figure out how to sort of
restructure the system so that we do
deal with these optional issues and
there's other optional issues by the way
in politics that I've talked to you
about as well okay a couple of other
articles just showing you what I'm
looking at for tomorrow a very
interesting article in Vanity Fair which
I alluded to before a crime in public
view how William bar pardoned Donald
Trump Trump had plenty of reasons to
obstruct molars investigation
whether or not there was an underlying
crime the most obvious one has been
staring us in the face all along this is
a very good article because it combines
number one this issue of how it's
difficult to know without knowing what
evidence there is without knowing what
is in Robert molars reports it's very
difficult to actually know how closely
does William bars for page summary
connect to what the full extent of
Robert Miller's report is but it also
goes into detail about a lot of the
other issues that are sort of
surrounding this and all of the other
reasons why even though Donald Trump
didn't personally collude with Putin
which I don't know really anyone who
believed that was going to be the
outcome of the investigation there were
still lots of reasons why Donald Trump
would want to obstruct the investigation
and I would argue did obstruct the
investigation in plain sight so I
recommend that you check out this art
what is this video very very strange I
recommend that you check out this
article by Scott Toro and I will be
using it as a source on tomorrow's
program also another article I'm looking
at and just the zoom on some of these is
atrocious I apologize a former
prosecutor explains why William bars
haste the obstruction conclusion should
raise red flags
yes this is a Democrat Renato Mariotti
who explains that this is simply it
simply cannot be fully explored if you
are actually open to the idea that
Donald Trump may be obstructed justice
in the 48 hour period that William bar
had to do it that the president did not
obstruct justice it's just not enough
time and fundamentally William bar is
not the person that should be making
that call historically it's been the
house as I've said and this article by
Renato Mariotti lays out a lot or
quoting Bernardo Mariotti by Sean ihling
points out a lot of the reasons why we
should be really really concerned about
that so a lot of reading that I've been
doing on this issue and it's depressing
that a lot of the articles about this
seem to be missing some pretty important
points that are kind of like crucial to
understanding what has happened and what
hasn't happened it's depressing when I
hear people talking about what's in
Moeller's report we don't know what's in
Mulder's report we haven't seen Muller's
report what we have is a four page
summary selectively put together by an
operative of the Trump administration
who was picked for his view on the
indictment of sitting presidents hint a
William Barr believed and said a year
ago that a sitting president cannot be
indicted for obstruction of justice
so as soon as anyone says my view of the
Moller report on the basis of having
seen the results is this you've not seen
it nobody's seen it publicly in any case
and you're not really making any sense
and that's sad and depressing okay Oh
wrong screen here it is a couple of
other super chats that I want to get to
I see a lot of people let me check out
the regular chat a lot of people in the
regular chat saying please open the
phone lines I've already said when we
get to ten new members I will open the
phone lines we are at five so we're not
that far if five more people sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership i will
right away open the phone lines and you
can call in at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty I have more time
than normal today to take phone calls
okay
so if you want to get more bang for your
buck out of signing up for a membership
during the stream tonight's a good night
because I will end up taking phone calls
for a while let me see what else is
happening in the regular chat David
you're a Zionist shill okay
pretty standard what else do we have
here
but-but-but Hillary's emails yeah we'll
talk we talked a little bit about that
today what else it's good that David
Pakman is doing these live streams more
often glad to do them for as long as
they are successful Trump has a Virgina
extraordinarily insightful comment thank
you what else do we have here a bunch of
people who are YouTube members saying
people should really sign up excellent
stuff okay so there's actually less
there's less anti-semitism in the chat
today than there typically is which is
nice okay Jaime Cravens asks should Dave
Rubin debate Sam cedar well if you're
asking me what I want to see it the
answer is yes if you're asking me should
Dave Rubin do it like as if I was
advising Dave as to what would be good
for him no I mean now I think if I'm
Dave Reubens rep I'm saying it's
probably best not to put yourself in
that position because I think we all
know what would happen right I think I
think so Jared Johnson with a fifty
Mexican peso super chat I'm on your side
would just like you to riff on how
social programs have helped in the
United States with specific numbers food
stamps Social Security etcetera yeah you
know we should do some long-form deep
dives into that Jared the problem is
that people generally have an
ideological position on whether there
should be food stamps that's more based
on whether they perceive anyone deserves
food stamps or whether they are sort of
sucking off the teat of government so to
speak so giving them the numbers you
know he here's how here's why we're very
careful Jared about how we pick our
long-form pieces we could spend a month
researching he
how many people are no longer hungry
because of food stamps here's how many
people can now retire at 69 instead of
75 of whatever because of Social
Security they would say that money put
into the free market system would have
generated more good and it's
indefeasible you can't say definitively
that it wouldn't have because it's not
what we did it's a silly argument but
that that's that's the risk and it would
end up not changing very many minds
which is depressing but unfortunately
the truth Augustine says David what's up
with your left ring finger oh yeah I I
was putting my drumset back together
today and after it was in storage for a
while as I've been moving and whatever
and I cut myself on something I don't
even know what it was I think I might
have been I was setting up a symbol and
next thing I knew my finger was bleeding
and that was it I will never play drums
again now tune in drop out I'm kidding
by the way tune in drop out has a twenty
five dollar super chat saying trying to
make sense of the media going all-in on
Trump Russia collusion from the jump
someone connected John Brennan must have
convinced the powers that be in the MSM
the fix was in and they had the goods on
Trump I don't know of any reason to
suggest that the reason corporate media
talked about the fact that this
investigation was going on is because
former CIA director John Brennan gave
them information that encouraged them to
do that if you have some particular
reason to make that assertion I would
love to hear it
but I don't have any reason to think
that were not for something John Brennan
told CNN CNN would not be covering this
this was a very serious investigation
into a lot of into several elements of
what took place expecting it to come
away with we caught Trump making a plan
with Putin to win the election that was
unrealistic from the get-go I have been
saying this from the get-go if anyone
was actually all in on on
illusion in the sense that they asserted
I know that there are some people on the
right like for example Bill Kristol who
said Trump's going to be perp-walked or
whatever I don't even I don't want to
misquote him but some thing about
Trump's gonna be caught here and it's
all bad nobody that I specifically heard
said the investigation will lead to
Trump being arrested or indicted for a
collusion with Russia he it appears he
obstructed justice in the light of day
that needs to be looked at by Congress
but I just don't agree with most of the
premises in your super chat tune and
drop out I apologize for that
although I appreciate the $25 super chat
the largest and most opulent and
luxurious of the evening okay we have
one more new member and that is douglas
levy levy or levy i never know how
different people pronounce that last
name thank you so much really appreciate
you signing up we are now at 6:00 and
looking for ten six and looking for ten
so the way that this will work is we
have a phone number it is six one seven
eight three zero 4750 if people want of
me to open the phones we just need four
more members okay membership is mostly
how this program is funded we produce
five one-hour shows a week five
15-minute members only
bonus bonus shows a week we distribute
the show for a free to two hundred radio
and television stations and two free
speech TV on DirecTV and Dish Network
which by the way doesn't pay us we
produce the show at our cost and we can
do all of that which I want to do and is
important to do because of the support
of people who have a couple of bucks a
month to spare so I don't want your last
two dollars but if you have two dollars
a month to spare and you believe what
we're doing is important then I am
asking for your support and I asked for
that support not pretending that you
don't have many options whether it's
supporting other shows or getting
yourself a latte or whatever it is that
you want to do and in order to encourage
you to do that
I will open the phone lines if we get
four new members and I also will offer
you two different discount codes this
evening if you want to save 40% off of
any membership the coupon code this is
20 20 will accomplish that for you if
you want to save $35 specifically off of
a $60 a year membership make one $25
payment forget about it for a year two
dollars and eight cents a month you can
use the coupon code save 35 that's a
secret coupon code that I am only
mentioning on live streams that has not
been mentioned outside of a couple of
days in February on the broadcast show
and it will not go on forever so I
suggest take advantage of the 25 dollar
deal for more members and I will open up
the phone lines and I look forward to
hearing from people judging by the way
from the chat going on I assume a lot of
people are going to call me out and for
what I don't know but I fully expect to
be called out if I open up the phone
lines and that'll be fine maybe we'll
even get some Trump is calling in soy
Bob also says your thoughts on am ello
AM L AM low is the abbreviation I
believe now for the New Mexican
president I listen I generally like the
guy and I think that his heart is in the
right place with a lot of his ideas
regarding corruption and cronyism I am
NOT following Mexican politics closely
enough to be able to issue what I would
consider a elaborate and detailed
critique of the current Mexican
president and I have no I'm not
interested in commenting on things that
I don't really have strong opinions on
it nor am i knowledgeable enough to
comment so I'm going to maybe next
weekend I'll spend some time getting up
to speed on what's going on with the
Mexican president but I don't know too
much about what he's actually been doing
since he became president
other than the airplane thing which I
guess he's done and he actually is
flying commercial
I guess or maybe I don't know if
Aeromexico is chartering planes for him
or whatever but I saw at least one
picture of him flying commercial don't
really know too much else about what's
going on there
mark Tenenbaum says thoughts on the
United States recognition of Golan
Heights stupid I mean just code totally
misguided as misguided as moving the
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem it
plays directly into the hands of
supporters of Benjamin Netanyahu and
it's but you know if if the goal is
actually moving towards
israeli-palestinian peace which is my
goal then it's just a bad idea
and you know it's it's red in the United
States
it's basically red meat throwing red
meat to the evangelical Christian
conservatives who like Israel but like
it for very selfish reasons their
support of Israel they believe is going
to bring about the second coming of
Christ and all of this just wacky
out-of-this-world stuff most American
Jews are on the left
Jews one of the most progressive voting
groups voted for Obama and just
extraordinary numbers so it's it's a bad
idea I'm against it as against it as I
was as I was as against it as I was
against moving the embassy from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem so that it's I I can't even
if I want to even steal man
recognising the Golan Heights as is
raised Israeli and come up with there's
some reason why it's a good I can't I
just simply can't come up with any
reason why it's even remotely defensible
Michael Ramirez is in the Super chat
with a dollar super chat no question or
comment very very much appreciate that
thank you so much and fool in the rain
with a five-dollar super shot fool in
the rain is one of my favorite Led
Zeppelin songs and in fact if you can
imagine this I'm 20 hold was I
25 years old 26 years old and I am
notified that I have won an award okay
the award is called 40 under 40
and it is 40 people under age 40 doing
something notable in western
Massachusetts where the david pakman
show started and everybody has to pick a
song to have their thing presented I
mean it was just it was the corniest
thing so immediately as soon as they say
please pick a song that will play as you
were called onstage to accept your award
I immediately say can I get out of this
because it sounds just horrible and this
is the I just hate I hate stuff like
that I will show up and give an hour
talk about a particular topic as I often
do but having my name said and an award
handed to me while a song plays gives me
gives me the chills so I tried to get
out of it but I couldn't and I ended up
picking the song fool in the rain by Led
Zeppelin in the end only like 13 seconds
of it played and the entire thing was an
anticlimactic and I don't know where the
award is now I think I've lost it or
it's in storage so there's a little
story for you okay let me do another
couple thank-yous Brian coldy which
could be the Brian Colby that I'm sort
of related to by marriage even though
I'm not married every time I say that
people get really confused is our newest
member using the coupon code this is 20
20 if this is Brian Cole D by the way if
this is well actually I shouldn't say
but bright there's big news actually I
just heard about Brian Cole D and it's
very exciting if it's the same one okay
thank you very much that is new member
number seven of the evening three more
three more and I will open up the phone
lines at six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty but you got to keep
them coming six one seven eight three
zero
4750 will be the next will be the phone
number if indeed we get three more
members I see some people in the regular
chat with some questions oh it is the
same one says Brian coldly very nice all
right good to see you there
xavier asking if I visit Buenos itis
with any frequency I go mostly once a
year and I was just actually looking for
plane tickets today because I'm hoping
to go this summer here which will be
winter there people don't know why I go
there regularly I was born there what
else but but but but how do other people
know it's the same Brian coal D that's
very strange
other people commenting about that did
Joe Rogan go on Alex's Jones show what's
up with that don't know anything about
that should avenatti run for president
yeah I don't think so not now that he's
been arrested again what else here
people like the Mexican president people
like the Mexican peso as a currency of
people like Massachusetts that's cool
can i play Moby Dick on the drums no I
mean I you know I could learn it in
parts but I don't know it offhand I do
know the intro to good times bad times
though it's a great song what else okay
let me get to another couple super chat
since people are sending them fool in
the rain says what do you think are the
chances that the molar report will
actually get released listen I think
eventually it will get released is it
going to be in its full unredacted form
I don't know I don't know until and if
we get the molar report we don't know
what Robert will are found out I mean
that's it that there's no you know
people are using language that is in
some way conditional or couching this in
certain ways if we don't see the full
molar report we don't know what the
truth is and that's it we just need to
see it
Jared Johnson says why do you prefer
Medicare for all over a public option
okay I prefer Medicare for all over a
public option because a public option
doesn't really deal with as many of the
problems of our system as Medicare for
all but I am actually not the biggest
Medicare for all supporter in the
context of all the other systems we
could have and what I mean by that is
the following if we are merely expanding
Medicare not just for people who are 65
and over as it exists now but to
everybody and no other changes are made
there are shortfalls in American
Medicare
80% of American Medicare recipients have
because they feel they need an
additional form of care
some people have private insurance that
they buy in addition to Medicare
supplement plans some people on Medicare
are also working and the Medicare works
with insurance that is provided through
their work some people on Medicare if
their income is low enough are also on
Medicaid and that's what supplements
what Medicare doesn't cover so I
actually think it's really important for
the left not to become blinded by
Medicare for all only because there's a
lot about how to pay for Medicare for
all we can totally pay for it there's a
lot about how Medicare for all is a
drastically better system than what we
have and I completely agree but if we're
actually going to look at all options
that exist there are other ideas that I
think are as good or potentially even
better than Medicare for all I've
outlined some of them before you can
check out my other videos about that
Matt Chavez says would you ever work
with TYT well you may not know this map
but I used to be part of a t YT network
and we did I think we joined when the
David Pakman show has like twenty
thousand YouTube subscribers long time
ago and we left when I had I think a
hundred and twenty thousand or so this
was like four years ago and it was all
with total peace and love and I still
see jenk once or twice a year and talk
to other people I just saw Ana Kasparian
at politican and we hung out before our
panel etc etc it was just that at we
were the David Pakman show grew large
enough that my call was I want to grow
our brand totally independent of what's
going on at TYT TYT had a whole bunch of
different shows with different opinions
and people started to sort of say David
is part of the TYT position on something
when of course every show is totally
independent and I decided I just want to
grow the brand totally independently it
can fail independently or it can succeed
independently but it will be
independent and so far so good we're now
at six hundred and twenty thousand
subscribers and it's amazing since we
left TYT Network we have added half a
million YouTube subscribers
Michael Ramirez has hey what do you
think is the possibility of Trump
getting tried when he leaves the office
very low I mean listen I'm out I'm sort
of pausing because there are only so
many ways I can say this the direct path
to removing Trump is voting in November
of 2020 it is unlikely Trump will ever
face consequences for everything he's
done impeachment is unlikely removal is
unlikely indictment is unlikely 25th
amendment stuff is unlikely we've just
got a vote and I think we just it
doesn't even make sense to focus on that
stuff because it's so extraordinarily
unlikely
Alessa Siebert's says love your show
with a $2 super Chad well thank you
Alyssa
really really appreciate that and on
that note we have one more new member
and that new member is oh this got
scrolled in a weird way went onto
another page that's weird George Azarian
George Azarian is the next new member
that is number 8 we are two members away
okay so I mentioned that I have more
time today to take phone calls than most
streams however were an hour in and we
have not hit 10 new members so I do
still have some time to take phone calls
but we got to just make it happen
quickly so my pitch to you is take
advantage of the coupon code save 35
it'll drop a $60 membership to
twenty-five bucks if two people do it I
will open up the phone lines and I see
that people are almost rabid in the chat
wanting the phone lines to open up one
person is saying I should play Aliza by
the way I'm sorry not Eliza ELISA
apologies for that
someone says play chess and then take
phone calls I mean I guess I could
potentially do that and if by the end of
the chest
game we have two more members I will
open up the phone lines I think people
just want to see me get crushed in chess
and that's actually why they want me to
play chess but let's do it I will take I
will play one game on leech s ok leeches
org I am David Pakman d-a-v-i-d
PA que ma n I'm on leech s now I will
play one game and then if indeed we get
two new members by the end of that game
I will open up the phone lines
otherwise I will probably just keep
taking Super chats so you can challenge
me at leeches org and I will probably
get crushed although I'm a little better
than I used to be it'd be bad it'd be
bad if I was getting worse and worse
right but anybody ranked above like a
thousand probably is able to to defeat
me so leech s org li CH s dot org I am
David Pakman on Leach s and I will play
one game and then if people want the
phone lines open this is this is sort of
it I mean www join pakman.com we have
like a I want to say 17 streams in a row
that we have achieved the 10 new members
in order to open the phone lines it
would be really depressed depressing if
we didn't achieve that today ok so mark
Tenenbaum has challenged me he has a
provisional rate rating of 1500 so I
will play against him and let's see how
we do
it could be excellent he might not be
and he seemed out there he goes ok very
good there is mark ok I'm in a play
Queens gambit as I have been playing
lately and you can't even see anything
here this is crazy there we go apologies
for that
ok standard Queens gambit accepted
opening mark Tannenbaum might be very
good he so far is playing a particular
line that I am familiar with let me zoom
this out so people can see the clock a
little bit better 10 minute game
unrated
yeah okay
mark developing I'm developing I wonder
if Mark actually plays chess regularly
in a castle hmm
all right there's a particular move here
yeah so there's this fork of the night
and Bishop can mark find a way not to
lose either of the pieces I don't know
could he put me in check okay so he can
attack there I think that's okay I think
I moved back and the fork is still in
play
can you get out of this I'm trying to
think here okay
orcs still there though where do I want
to go next probably here he's avoided
losing a piece so far but I don't know
if ultimately he can ah yeah
interesting I guess that was the way
okay uh what we doing next here I'll
push this pawn forward people can tell
I'm terrible I think so I have this
check then what does he do the King can
only move okay if I go here I think the
king has to come here and then do I have
another check I really don't I don't
know if that's a useful move um do I
want to do here
maybe I just take the free pawn first
and then I'm attacking the knight and
maybe I can put the king in check can
also take the bishop if he doesn't move
it either way it's a little bit dicey
there
um I'm in check or do I take the bishop
I'm actually unsure so I take the bishop
where does mark go next I wonder what
people are saying by the way in the chat
he's gonna castle
well he can't castle right now yeah
that's what he had to do so let's see if
I put him in check here um that mate I
put him in check
no it's not oh right now of course not
because you can put the bishop there the
rook there rather think that there's
only move here
I think he has to come here yep now
let's see if I go here he has to go back
here then maybe I put him in check with
the bishop I think I like that idea
there we go okay good game have no idea
if mark regularly plays chess or or
doesn't play chess but appreciate the
game do we have any other man that this
everything just went dead
we got no new members and we got no
super chats during that people either
extremely captivated by the chess game
or we're not liking it whatsoever and I
don't know which of the two it was but I
appreciate everybody entertaining that
okay let's take a look at the top
stories on the David Pakman show
subreddit okay let's take a look here
and this is sort of last call by the way
four live calls last call for live calls
we are two away if people want me to
open the phone lines this is sort of the
we just need two more members at WWE and
pokémon calm and I don't know sometimes
people say David why not open the phone
lines anyway and it's because if we have
some target and we don't reach it and I
open the phone lines anyway then people
would have no reason to sign up to get
the phone lines open right doesn't make
any sense so I do have to stick to it if
we don't reach to two more new members
which would get us to ten I cannot open
the phone lines because that would be
completely and utterly inappropriate of
me to do let's see what's happening on
the David Pakman show
subreddit let's see if I can zoom this
out a little bit what is on people's
minds man this it's not very easy to see
let's see here no that's not a good zoom
okay here we go top story molar report
concludes Clinton campaign and DNC were
hacked by the Russian government it was
not a leak as many have claims yeah I
brought that up on the Regular Show
today that's an interesting issue which
is not being discussed which is people
on the right end
who love WikiLeaks or just were kind of
Russia deniers insisted that it wasn't
Russia who hacked the DNC and Hillary
Clinton and that it also was not
WikiLeaks who coordinated with Russia to
release that information and Muller
determined if we believe William bar
that it was and the deniers on that
issue are just totally silent they're
not saying anything one way or the other
what an interesting thing beta or work
gets all the attention but Elizabeth
Warren's proposals are leading the 2020
pack I think that that's an interesting
story as well that we will be talking
about Michael avenatti arrested on
federal charges of wire fraud and
extortion Trump is having the best day
in two years it seems that's funny that
they're saying the poster says Trump's
having his best day in two years
tomorrow I'm doing a story called
yesterday meaning today was the best day
for Trump of his presidency which
includes the 24/7 right-wing media
vindication cycle and Michael avenatti
now facing according to one legal expert
potentially up to 50 years in prison
which is extraordinary
Trump signals support for reports
release as Democrats dispute exoneration
one nation under stress the documentary
lifting the lid on American anxiety that
seems interesting I would be interesting
interested in seeing that bars summary
of molars report is not a condemnation
of David that's interesting well what is
this about was David's actual position
what was David's actual position on the
issue of Trump Russia collusion this
phone conversation between David and a
caller is instructive here's the
relevant excerpt I love this David let's
go next to our caller from the six one
six area code caller I was wondering do
you personally think that Donald Trump
colluded with Russia like just your
personal thought David as an individual
that Trump personally was like talking
to Putin and setting things up yeah like
do you think Putin installed some guy
who doesn't know what he's doing in our
government and now he's just here David
we'll hold on that's two different
things
let's take them I love these transcripts
let's take them one at a time if that's
okay all right question one is do I
think Trump was directly involved in
coordination with
agents I think the answer is probably no
I think Trump was aware that his
campaign was talking to Russian actors
but I think the likelihood of Trump
personally coordinating and anything is
probably close to zero Wow okay well I
actually should clip that I appreciate
that
I should clip that for tomorrow's show
because that's an important thing
contra points is Natalie win on fascism
and authoritarianism yes my interview
with Connie welcome well the program's
hits inception my interview with Natalie
is now up and I hope you will check it
out it is very very very interesting and
she was very nice to speak to me
half-hour interview which I think people
will like if you like that interview
please consider becoming a member as
well very very much appreciated so some
interesting stuff there on the David
Pakman show
subreddit let's see what else we've got
Jay ymf 33 is a new member that gets us
to nine oh and Marcus Davis also became
a new member which gets us to 10 okay so
I will open up the phone lines we have
done it it took a very very very long
time but we have done it so I will open
up the phone lines and hear from people
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 you can call in now
if you would like keep signing up keep
sending super shots Sam Dean what is
your opinion on the Jim Jefferies secret
recording I don't know what that is I'm
not sure what the Jim Jefferies secret
recording is let's see just Jim
Jefferies secret recording let's see avi
Yemeni exposes Jim Jefferies with a
hidden camera ok I mean let's see what
this is all Don a second
oh yeah I'm very acutely finding myself
not caring about this just on just just
based on what I've seen so far I'm
finding it I don't I'm not finding that
super interesting I don't know who
either of those people are and I'm kind
of checked out okay Ann Kennedy has sent
the tude up with peace and love I say
that Sam by the way Ann Kennedy has sent
a $2 super chat which I very much
appreciate and let me let me go to the
phones here okay let me get myself
connected first at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty we've got a
bunch of people holding and I think
it'll be great to see what's on people's
minds a lot of repeat callers a lot of
new callers are here just taking me a
second to get myself connected and then
we will see what is on people's minds
okay let's go first to O'Brien from
Seattle is on the phone who was sort of
like involved in calling in and talking
about Ronald Reagan on the Sam cedar
show and he's been trying to get a hold
of me so what's going on Brian what did
you need to tell me hey so yeah what
happened there I I thought I was just
kind of calling to discuss the whole
thing I thought it was a little silly I
still do and apparently now there's I'm
part of some kind of conspiracy theory
or something so there's been all sorts
of comments that I am Ronald Reagan
using a voice modulator I it's it's
interesting and now I know how you feel
when you get comments constantly
accusing you of weird conspiracy theory
stuff I guess well I don't even know
about any of this so I what you're
telling me right that doesn't matter I
guess I just wanted to call in and
clarify like because some people thought
I was being too hard on on him and I
realized that he was being largely
tongue-in-cheek and so I wasn't like
calling and being like yeah he was
totally serious I mean like some people
thought I was saying that Reagan doesn't
have anything valuable to say or like
trashing him and to clarify if I did
that that wasn't my intention I think he
has like you know clearly from from what
I've seen of him on the show he knows a
lot about the topics that he talks about
on the show
it makes sense to have an attorney who
deals with immigration talk about
immigration so your I'm not opposed to
that and I didn't mean to if I suggested
otherwise that wasn't my intention
so I guess this is the part that he can
edit out later if he wants to say that
unreasonable or whatever but I just
wanted to clarify that I wasn't like
trying everything and trying to trash
the majority report or anything
particularly I thought that you really
do that's I didn't think so either but I
got a bunch of stuff in the comments
being like and then Brian calls into
trash Sam cedar and majority record and
I'm like what I know that's not it so I
did I just wanted to clarify I tried to
call in on the last livestream but to be
honest I'm a little relieved you didn't
take the call because I didn't want to
try and follow up Jimmy of course he was
the first caller and I was on hold and I
was like I don't know how I can follow
that up advisement and maybe Ronald
Reagan is listening here I don't know
maybe he maybe he's holding he I know
he's been trying to call in as well but
on that note great and and I apologize I
didn't get to ask you in advance if I
could you know I kind of ruined the
whole conspiracy interest angle I guess
and I I didn't know if you wanted me to
do that just clarified that I wasn't
saying anything outlandish or that you
know I wasn't trying to take it too
seriously um before you go can I make a
quick comment on the molar thing okay
just real brief I know I don't want to
do B relish you and I got a lot of
people holding um I I just don't
understand that how anyone got the
impression that all that that everyone
on the left was saying this whole time
is that when the Muller report dropped
that was going to be the be-all end-all
there's a lot of different things going
on and that's not all of them you know
and I don't quite understand how
everyone thought that what all of us
liberals were saying was he had one
similar reports out he's going to be
impeached instantly and it's all over
that's you know I don't think you gave
that impression and I think most of the
rest of us did but that's what I'm
hearing and it's like no guys it's not
done it doesn't make him you know not
corrupt just that this particular
thing it wasn't as devastating as we
would have liked so I guess that's just
my short response to that all right from
you appreciate the phone call and I'm
gonna let you go because the the phone
lines are just exploding at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I'm gonna go next to our caller
from the 9 1 7 area code caller from 9 1
7
what's your name where you calling from
hi David how's it going this is a victor
from New York City hey Victor hi how's
it going
ok so my question is about do you think
that Bernie's of foreign-policy leanings
will hurt him in the primary and I have
an example beside here yeah there's this
act called the justice again sponsors of
Terrorism Act and it's essentially a law
that allows US citizens to sue foreign
powers that were you know aiding or were
directly involved in terrorist attacks
that harm them or people in the United
States
it basically unanimously passed the
Senate when 97 senators in support with
the one opposing vote being Center
menorah leader
Larry Harry Reid but the two abstaining
votes were Tim Kaine and the other
standing vote with Bernie Sanders you
know that's the thing like I I just
don't really feel comfortable with that
and I'll be gone I'm a bernie guy all
the way it should with this issue in
particular I think he kind of has a soft
spot and there's a little hesitant to
deal with foreign powers in an
aggressive way and I think that might
hurt him what's your thoughts on that
well listen I don't know about that bill
specifically but it's interesting you
bring this up today because on the
Friday show one of the audience
questions I'm going to be answering is
where what what is the strongest
criticism of Bernie Sanders and again
I'm gonna be I'm Bernie's in my top
three candidates as well so I'm going to
be steel Manning I'm gonna be making the
strongest possible arguments against
Bernie one of them which I've been
researching is that he does seem to lack
lack the knowledge that he has with such
specificity and depth on domestic issues
I believe he may lack to some degree on
geopolitics and international issues and
foreign policy so I think that what
you're mentioning is interesting I'll
research that particular bill but it
seems like you're you're thinking along
similar lines as I am when it comes
what our what our Bernie's weaknesses
right yeah because I mean that bill was
actually vetoed by Obama and had to be
yet to be overturned by the Senate so it
was just interesting and I just want to
get your opinion on that thank you all
right thank you very much appreciate the
call let's go next to our caller from
the 6-5 zero area code caller from six
five zero who's this
I uh
Darius you're not on speakerphone are
you no I'm not okay cuz it sounds like
you are hear me now yeah all of a sudden
it's better thank you all right now it's
bad again so Darius I don't know if it's
the signal or some kind of headset or
something but you're you're very quiet
and crackling again is a good now that
was better
all right and now it's bad okay well
just yell your question Darius and then
I'll take it alright so um so regarding
we're going that's nothing happening on
Twitter with you and Kyle do you think
like do you have anything else to say
about that because it's interesting to
see like the disparity of what the left
has to say about the Malheur report and
what happened recently oh no I mean for
people who don't know what's going on so
yesterday I posted something how you
know I'm getting all these tweets from
so-called leftists who are who would
normally question the conclusions of the
law enforcement law enforcement world
are just kind of accepting what William
Barr is saying and that's kind of weird
to me and yeah something along those
lines I think I I hope I'm paraphrasing
right and I think Kyle kolinsky
responded with something like not sure
why leftists is in quotation marks and
he said something about what his
position was and I said oh I wasn't
talking about you I don't even know what
your position has been on this issue I
don't really watch any progressive shows
and know that way and I haven't heard
anything back alright so okay well
that's it cool okay alright Darius Clara
glad to answer your question we're
taking calls at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty if you
would like to join the conversation call
in at six one seven eight three zero
4750 I'll go next to the caller from the
4:01 area code who's calling today from
four zero one hey David this is mark
from Newport and you just totally kicked
my butt and chest oh good game oh that
was you okay great mark Tenenbaum great
did you normally play chess or did you
make an account to play against me
I actually made an account to play
against you about one of your previous
livestream yeah so as soon as I heard
you meant to lead chess I just dialed
odds and a challenge very nice
okay well thank you for the game yeah
sure so a couple weeks ago one of your
viewers called in and he asked if he
supported both ubi and an increase in
the minimum wage and you said you
supported both because they each serve
different purposes so in gurgaon who
you've interviewed and who is running on
UPI tweeted that he does not support an
increase in the minimum wage because it
will exacerbate automation so I just
wanted to know your your thoughts on
that or if you have a response uh well I
don't have a response to Andrew yang I
didn't see his comment but I think that
he heard it's interesting because he has
ways of dealing with the move to
automation that would that aren't
mentioned if you just talk about the
minimum wage and ubi in other words
there there's the idea of taxing robot
labor right when robots replace people
in certain industries you can add a tax
on that to disincentivize the
replacement of someone with a person I'm
not saying it's a good idea or a bad
idea I'm not debating the idea I'm just
saying it exists and I know Andrew yang
is aware of that so I mean I I disagree
I don't you need to have a minimum wage
that has at least kept up with inflation
over the last several decades and our
current minimum wage doesn't so I don't
know if you're at this point in time if
you don't want a $15 minimum wage you're
basically saying you agree with a lower
minimum wage today than what we had in
1968 inflation adjusted and I don't know
how you possibly defend that okay well
hey thank you very much okay thank you
appreciate the call okay
who is next here let's go - lets go -
kujan who Orcas hoon I never am sure if
I've even written it down correctly but
I'm sure he will tell me we haven't
heard from him since last year what's
going on Kishan
hey you got the name correct this time
was it kuzey on Orcas hoon who John
Kluge on ok good what's going on Kishan
um so I was recently watching a video I
think it was Symons school system ok I
was looking at the way that you know the
like how the teenagers there have kind
of like less anxiety they're able to
develop their social skills better I
think I heard that like on average they
usually like they barely have homework
or you know just you know it's barely
it's barely any homework ok so I was my
question was like would that necessarily
work in the United States and if it
worse like if were to work like how
would you implement that are you talking
specifically about just giving kids less
homework no not necessarily giving
people less homework but like creating
education system where like you're
taking the stress off of them but like
at the same time you're objectively I
don't like the you're still educating
them but it's just that you're taking
less pressure off them of course you
know of course of course I mean listen
the time of day that school starts is
the source of anxiety for a lot of kids
and counterproductive the amount of
homework kids have in the context of
extracurricular activities causes it
stress and anxiety the amount of
extracurricular activities that a lot of
kids have are problematic so yeah
there's no reason whatsoever that if we
decided that that's something we wanted
to fix we we could fix for sure it would
work just as well with American kids as
with kids in Scandinavia or any other
places it's the question of whether
there's the desire and the will to
actually do it and make it happen but
how do
things that would be implemented try
like federally this you mean from Ali or
how do well no I don't know that you can
implement it federally I mean that the
in the United States a lot of education
is decided about at the state level so
more than likely it would have to be
done at the state level but in terms of
how I mean I'm not an expert in
education but I would look at how other
countries have done it and I would try
to implement it in a similar fashion all
right good all right Kushan great to
hear from you
six 178 3-0 47 50 let's go next to our
caller from the five six three area code
who's calling from five six three hey
David this is he hey Heath what's going
on I was wondering you know uh I'm on
SSDI and I have been for a couple years
okay and I see the reports and what
Donald Trump wants to do with our Social
Security disability you know although
although what they call entitlement
right and I was wondering and I'm sure
you've spoke about this before but I was
wondering what are your views on say
like a universal health care like
Finland or Sweden oh I'm in favor I
would work out spoken in favor of
removing profit from health care
involving the government could be as
single-payer could be with a
nationalized system like in the UK all
of these are options I'm in favor of in
combination with each other one of the
most important issues I've dealt with
for sure on the program well yeah
exactly that's what I would say and you
know I was just coming back to it
because like I said I just saw Donald
Trump want to throw that out there for
the Congress to pass and right kind of
scary yes I'm against cutting that and
you you're we've need a different system
and could not could not agree with you
more if that's the point you're making
for sure yes for this thank you very
much David okay I appreciate the phone
call let's see
we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our caller from the 5:03
area code who's calling from 5 0 3 hello
this is Anne I'm in Oregon hey Anne
what's going on well I have a question
for you about primaries there's so many
issues we could talk about but right now
I'm going to talk about primaries in
Oregon we don't have a lot of chance to
weigh in on the primaries so everything
happens in Iowa and the other early
states so it feels to me like I don't
even care who's running right now
because it'll all get ironed out later
it's very frustrating
yes I understand and sympathize with you
as far as that goes I don't know I mean
short of changing how the system works
you know it's all about who is favored
in at the expense of someone else so the
electoral college system favors a
particular slate of small more rural
states that vote early instead of the
population centers so the population
centers get less attention the primary
system gives more power to decide who
the nominees will be to the earlier
States to vote rather than the later
States yeah I mean you're right this is
it's what it is and it's one of the
problems with the system yeah and so I
have to tell you the truth I find myself
not really interested in who's
announcing to run right now because I
figured by the time they get here it'll
be a whole translate right no but but
you're not so you're not apathetic about
removing Trump it sounds like you're
just saying following the comings and
goings at this point in the primary
process doesn't seem like a particularly
good use of time because it may well be
decided by the time it gets to you
absolutely uh certainly we need to get
rid of this guy no and you could if you
found a candidate you liked you could
phone bank for her right and help them
learn the early primaries you could
donate there are things you can do yeah
that's for sure yep okay well so who do
you like so far though is there anyone
you like oh I like Bernie a lot
probably he's the best one for me right
now okay
would you consider elizabeth warren oh
maybe I'm not I've not gotten really
red-hot about her and is it so they're
very similar on policy is there a policy
difference or is it a personality
difference that makes you prefer for me
it yeah it's just personality it's just
me being here interesting and last
question and I'll let you go
electability do you care about
electability at this point you know we
have to get rid of this guy so we have
to think about it and I'm very sorry
about that because we should be I think
doing so many things that are different
in this country than what we're doing
right now
yep and to have to think about
electability rather than who's the best
for the country yeah it's ridiculous
alright and thank you for the call I
appreciate it thank you very much David
okay take care
let's see Boston hey David taking my
call what's going on yeah so I was just
thinking about this I've heard the
argument made before that selectively
Medicare Medicaid and the VA already
cover about 40% of Americans but I
really don't see this argument really
being made when it comes to advocating
for Medicare for all or a similar
single-payer system so what do you think
about that should it be should it be
used more often what's the I'm not sure
I understand what what do you mean what
the argument is so the argument being
that we're already in a sense covering
almost 40% of the country through a
combination of these programs so in a
way is it really as daunting as people
are making it out to seem Oh from the
point of view of when people say we
can't do what Sweden does because we're
such a big country or whatever you're
already doing it by doing it for forty
percent that's already more people than
live in Sweden or wherever that's kind
of what I'm getting at yeah what do you
think about that it's an interesting
argument I mean so then you very quickly
get into the nitty-gritty which are for
example of that
40 percent how many are covered by
Medicare and then you get to well 80% of
those covered by Medicare are covered by
Medicare plus something else like either
Medicaid or private insurance or
whatever it's not full coverage that
most people are getting and then with
Medicaid you can say well you know the
problem with Medicaid is that it's a
system set up to cover people on the
basis of lack of income so if you
actually have a country that lifts more
people out of poverty you're going to
remove people from that system it's not
a system meant to cover everybody it's
meant a system to cover the poor or
people below certain levels of income so
I agree with you about the stupidity of
the talking point that this would never
work in the u.s. because of the u.s. is
too big that doesn't make sense it's
never made sense however if the idea is
to come up with some kind of like
bulletproof argument to use against the
right they're always going to have some
kind of talking point to respond with so
then it's a question of how many people
can you convince with it and I don't
know you know whether it would be
effective for that yeah I'm definitely
curious about that point as well and
yeah definitely good point about the
right yeah that's all I really had for
you David just a quick question I had
okay you're taking thanks appreciate
hearing from you Nick in Boston let's go
to our caller from the nine one nine
area code who's calling from nine one
nine today it's Robert from Atlanta hey
Robert what's going on so just wondering
why you think the Democrats haven't
talked about the NSA or government
surveillance recently or have very
there's not much of an advantage to
talking about it right now it's messy in
that a lot of that surveillance was
happening under Obama so from a
political standpoint it doesn't seem
like it's massively advantageous to make
it an issue it's not clear that it's a
voting issue it's not clear that
Democrats win on that issue because
Democrats and Republicans both have been
by and large complicit or standing by as
that surveillance went on so it's I can
think of a lot of reasons why they're
not talking about it because I was
really disappointed reading the tegu de
Jose for example yeah is incredibly
critical of Snowden Chelsea Manning
and now that was like a deal breaker for
me yeah I haven't seen that about him
but that's that's interesting and I
think it's basically it's it's an issue
there's not much upside to talking about
the issue so I think they're not talking
about it quite simply okay oh pretty
good
all right appreciate it great from the
call great to hear from a bunch of
people that does it for me tonight I
will stream again in the future when I
don't know but I'll be sure to let you
know the next time a stream is happening